what's going on guys this is Rob and you
know so I went back and I was watching
the Civil War part three and I'm not
happy with that video you know I was
gonna really like when I made that I
thought it was good like when I made it
and I finished it I said okay cool this
is short and concise
it'll give people exactly what they want
and then I uploaded it you know of
course I had like 5 minutes of time
added on to it I know I'm I didn't even
realize what I was doing I've Wonder
Premiere Pro and I I adjusted settings
and I don't know I was I was doing it
with half a brain so but you know I was
looking at the video and I was like man
this this videos like it's not up to my
usual standard for videos it's not up to
what you guys are used to and it set up
to what I'm used to putting you know I
mean when I'm when I'm doing videos you
know my idea is I want to give you guys
details that really kind of give you a
broad scope that really give you like a
really good understanding of what's
going on you know so you guys can look
at that and say okay I understand Tony
Starks frame of mind in this you know
for example one of the things that I
left out that I kind of wish I hadn't is
before Tony Stark and Iron Man get into
a fight or a Tony Stark in Captain
America get into a fight Tony Stark
tries to not fight these he's like look
let's just kind of try to come to this
amicably and as a chance for us to see
Tony Stark you know in the sense that
he's not doing this as like a mad grab
for hunt or for power he's not doing
this because he's crazy or anything like
that he thinks he's doing the right
thing and that kind of contributed to it
and in hindsight I really you know I
really wish I'd added that in there but
at the time you know I was I was I was
thinking okay you guys are coming off
basically like 40 minutes worth of tie
ins like Civil War part 1 I'm sorry the
Civil War issue number 2 tie ins part 1
and part 2 came out to be like 40
minutes roughly I figured I was
uploading the video the same day I don't
want to like bombard you guys with like
you know 40 minutes worth of video in
one day that was my thought process you
know and and in hindsight like I should
have just said the hell with that
I'll just you know whatever I'll give
them 40 minutes and they'll be happy
with it yeah I don't know
you know it just if that rushed like the
video just felt really rushed it just
felt like you know I came on and I said
well Civil War issue number three picks
up where Civil War number two ended and
this some stuff happens Captain America
and Iron Man fight done thanks for
watching guys peace that's what it felt
like you know when I made that video
it's just it felt really really short
and you know I think it could have been
more expansive and I think that the
reason why it was so short was because I
was kind of rushing through it because I
just kind of wanted to get it done and
uploaded you know and and that's a bad
thing that's a problem because I think
that one of the reasons why you guys
really enjoy my content is because it is
so detour detail-oriented because I can
take a comic book you know or take a
character you know like Iron Man or even
a character that we've done in the past
you know like the Winter Soldier Bucky
Barnes and I can make a 20 minute video
on him and give you guys the entire
scoop when it comes to Bucky Barnes
Bucky Barnes scoop is not that difficult
like it's not that big it's really not
even that expansive Bucky Barnes was in
World War 2 Bucky Barnes showed up at
two thousand five from Ed Brubaker that
was his return to Marvel Comics he was
the Winter Soldier he did some stuff and
then some stuff happens I'm not gonna
spoil you guys you know what happens
later on with Bucky Barnes but you know
that's like it's really like not that
difficult I could explain Bucky Barnes
in three minutes if I wanted to but you
know I really like bringing like
detail-oriented stuff to you guys I
really like bringing things that really
kind of have my personal take on it who
you know like what do I really think
about Bucky Barnes those Bucky Barnes
was it worth bringing him back what is
it a good idea to do so I mean I think
so Bucky Barnes is a great dynamic
character and Marvel Comics especially
now and the current original sin
storyline of Marvel Comics my god he's a
great character Nick Fury is the same
way you know I mean there's these are
really great characters and I'm glad
they're back you know because they can
really contribute in a fantastic way to
Marvel Comics but you know um the detail
orientation I think is one of the things
that they're really kind of I guess
maybe drives you guys to watch my videos
and I feel like if I'm uploading videos
that don't honor that if I'm not
building videos that don't really kind
of like delve into this detail
orientation then why do it at all you
know because I think this is really what
kind of sets me apart this is really
what kind of you know draws people in is
you know this whole trifecta that myself
and Benny and Dave have you know it
works out so perfect it works out so
well
and if one of us isn't doing what we're
supposed to do then the whole
things come toppling down and I don't
want it to be that way you know I want
to be the detail orientation guys so so
the question is why why was that video
so rushed why was why was it not up to
my usual par well honestly and the guys
might not like this answer because I
just wanted to get it out and be done
with it you know because I had come off
a civil war the civil war tions Part one
and Part two you know and those took me
about a week apiece to make just because
they're so expansive the the tie-ins
there's there's so much going on there
that it's difficult to really sit down
and to say okay you know how can I give
you guys the story without making the
videos so expansive been so long and
going into every single minut detail
that you guys would just inevitably lose
interest in the video I mean how can i
how can I do that and that was the most
difficult part was really trying to
trying to get that arranged in such a
way so coming up all right we have 22
tie-ins that we're gonna be doing and
when I was looking at that I was like oh
my god this is a daunting task and I was
sitting here and I was like I don't even
know if I want to do that and that's the
problem it was the fact that I didn't
know if I wanted to do it this is
something that I love I I love doing
videos on comic books I love talking to
you guys it's something that I think is
it's so fun and so entertaining but I
think I'm kind of starting to get burned
out I think I'm starting to kind of get
to that point where I'm like I'm not
really sure I want to do this so we're
gonna take a break we are going to take
a break for about a week and a half or
so and I'm gonna regain my bearings I'm
gonna really kind of get back into this
pattern and get back to what it is that
I love because I don't want to stop
doing this you know I don't I don't ever
want to stop doing this I want to do
this for as long as I can
and I want to bring you guys videos for
as long as I can and I don't want to end
up as one of these guys that gets burned
out and then starts going through a
whole mishmash of stuff on their channel
and just go through this goes through
this like identity crisis and what they
want their channel to be there anything
my channel is a comic book channel for
the most part it is going to be coming
books the run and the majority of all
the videos that I'm gonna upload are
going to be coming book channels I'm not
a gaming channel but what we are going
to do for the next week and a half as
play games because I'm not just gonna
bail on you guys I'm not just gonna
disappear on you guys and just
uploading any Content we're gonna play
some video games so we're gonna play
some Borderlands 2 we're gonna play some
co-op games I mean the steam summer
sales going on guys buy games um you
know I want to play Borderlands 2 you
and I want to play with Dave I don't
know if biddies on border and I think
Benny said he didn't want to play I
think he comes back next week is when he
gets back home from VidCon so I want to
have you know me Benny and Dave playing
video games and I want one of you guys
to play with us why don't you
subscribers to play with it so if you
have Borderlands 2 send me a message you
know and say Rob I want to play
Borderlands 2 and and you myself and
Dave and another guy from you know
another subscriber we can all play
Borderlands until Benny gets back and
then biddings of course gonna take the
third spot but my cat is clawing my god
I hate it when my dad does that but um
anyway I'm gonna I want to take a break
I do not under any circumstances want to
get burned out on this this is too fun
for me to get burned down on this it's
too much fun and it's so fun to interact
with you guys so I don't want to be one
of these guys it's just like I just
don't want to do this anymore you know I
love doing this it's fun it's exciting
it's really really interesting my
channel is growing so much because of
you guys helping me out and you guys
really kind of guiding me and helping me
grow so so like I said we're gonna take
a break we're gonna take a break for
about a week and a half and we're going
to play some video games and I'm gonna
regain my bearings and next week I think
next Thursday
I'm off for ten straight days so I got
the bursts so starting with those 10
straight days where I'm gonna go back
into the habit I'm gonna start making
some more videos and I'm gonna crank
these videos out I'm gonna get them
uploaded for you guys but I just I you
know I don't I don't want to get to a
place where I hate doing this where I
feel like you know where I feel like
it's become a job I don't want this to
be to feel like a job you know and I
think that's the worst thing you can do
with a hobby so I want to make sure that
I'm always refreshed I want to make sure
that I'm always comfortable doing what
it is that I do and I want to make sure
that it's all worth it always stays
interesting so today is what's
technically 12 a.m. on the 24th which is
a Tuesday so starting today we're gonna
take a break and we're gonna pick back
up probably not this coming Monday but
the Monday after that so we'll have a
video uploaded by then we'll see we'll
see maybe might even be that next
day so we can keep up with the whole
tions thing but nonetheless you know
what we'll get it sorted out but I'll be
live-streaming the whole time when we're
playing video games next week is when
I'll be live-streaming like during the
day and stuff but for right now I'll
probably live streaming it you know
11:30 midnight something like that it's
because that's when I get off work or I
might be live-streaming it like 10:00 in
the morning or sub along those lines I
worked 3 p.m. to 11 p.m. normally so I
can of course livestream during those
times but but yeah so anyway I think
I've kind of rambled on long enough I
need to get my place together and get
cleaned up and everything get my place
cleaned up it's a total wreck like like
I need to show you guys my place
sometime it's it's a it's alright now is
the total wreck but when it's cleaned up
then I'll show you guys but anyway so so
yeah so um that's it peace